WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi there.
I'm Wayne Piekarski for
"The Developer Show."
And this is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
The .dev domain is now
available to anyone through
your registrar of choice.
We envision .dev as a home
for developers from tools
to programming
languages and blogs.
For some links to a few of
our favorite sites on .dev,
or to register your own,
check out the post linked
in the description below.
Flutter 1.2 is now available and
focuses on a few major areas--
improved stability,
performance, and quality
of the core framework, visual
finish and functionality
of existing widgets, and
new web-based tooling.
For a lot more detail
and links to get started,
head on over to the post.
Go 1.12 is now available.
Highlights include opt-in
support for TLS 1.3,
improved module support,
support for Windows on ARM,
and improved Mac OS and
iOS forwards compatibility.
A link to the download
page is on the post.
The Cloud IoT Device
SDK is a new way
for embedded IoT devices to
connect to Google Cloud IoT
core.
And with the Google
Cloud IoT platform,
you can now manage
all of your devices,
establish data streams
with analytics tools
such as BigQuery or Bigtable,
monitor performance,
and visualize data.
Links to get started
are on the post.
The Google Summer of
Code is a global program
focused on bringing more student
developers into open source
software development.
The open-source projects
and organizations
that have been accepted for
Google Summer of Code 2019
are linked from the post.
If you're a student
interested in participating,
now's the time to take a look.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Wayne Piekarski for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: What about the--
what about the Winter of Code?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: We
don't have such a thing.
SPEAKER: That was-- that was--